when you visit a city as a tourist you
might notice a pattern in how you move
around namely you have some points or
interest some landmarks you want to
check out and in order to get there you
have to charge through areas that are
just whatever in order to get to the few
nice places you're gonna go through the
boring often unpleasant places this
usually manifests itself in a friendly
quiet human scale but very touristy
Center which is surrounded by the loud
disappointing whatever areas I.E the
rest of the city but those areas weren't
always like that they too were once
friendly quiet and human scale just like
the touristy Center but while the center
was mostly preserved in its original
form the rest of the city was
effectively gutted and tombing it in
metric tons of concrete and asphalt
leading to areas that are just lame
disappointing unpleasant dangerous even
but above all uninspiring and completely
forgettable
if you look at Postcard pictures of
different streets and compare them to
how they look today you'll note that
back in the day the areas had character
they looked inviting vibrant Pleasant or
at the very least interesting and
memorable compared those postcard
pictures to the current state of affairs
those interesting areas are now the same
dull Bland unpleasant whatever places
that you just rush through on your way
to the few remaining nice places that's
why City centers are so choked with
tourists they all go there because
chances are that's the only area worth
visiting as a whole the only area where
you can just be where you can hang
around and have a good time through that
alone tourists won't spread out across
the city because the rest of the city
just isn't worth seeing here I'm not
talking about the few interspersed
landmarks but the Sea of uninteresting
unpleasant dullness around them the lame
disappointing unpleasant uninteresting
forgettable and often dangerous
quote-unquote regular areas back then it
wasn't like that you could spend weeks
even months just walking around cities
discovering it bit by bit observing the
locals getting lost in its Urban fabric
today why would you outside the calm
touristy Center everything is loud like
a really loud the air is polluted and
you're just shimmying along the
buildings dodging parked cars and
scooters if you stop to admire the
surroundings people will think you're
trying to break into a car or something
also and I can't stress this enough it's
hard to really experience an area it's
culture its architecture and its people
when cedario sounds like this
the buildings for someone's around you
might be nice but the streets themselves
are all the same car Road parking Lanes
narrow sidewalks car Road parking Lanes
narrow sidewalks
car Road parking Lanes narrow sidewalks
turning over our streets to cars in my
opinion has caused an even bigger issue
than the geometric lack of human
friendly public spaces namely that we
expelled ourselves our Humanity our
spirit if you will from our cities which
used to be the mortar inside the urban
Fabric in such disappointing unpleasant
uninteresting forgettable areas we will
rarely find any culture fun inspiration
social experiences no memories will be
created nothing interesting will be
happening between the patched asphalt
lanes and the rivers of parked cars this
is a form of urban death or rather
undeath where the streets are still
there and people still use them but
everyone is just going through the
motions everyone is just shuffling past
eyes pointed forward or blasting the
screen of their smartphone trying to
push through the area it's a lifeless
imitation of a street hence the term
Urban undeath no longer a place for
people but a traffic thorough air to
Channel people towards the few Pleasant
places remaining a few islands in the
sea of great dullness but it doesn't
have to be like that there is a way to
bring life back to a city by
deprioritizing individual motor traffic
cars in favor of everyone else as in the
silent majority not planning everything
around course will result in the
traditional human-centric streets and
places compact enough to walk or cycle
through this is how every city was built
throughout history right until the Auto
industry bought her politicians and
hijacked urban planning departments to
build cities accommodating their
products instead of people living there
but once you end unrestricted individual
motor traffic once you shift your focus
to everyone else the majority streets
squares entire districts suddenly come
to life the city will be full of
memorable inspiring Pleasant calm human
friendly areas you can simply get lost
in in a good sense where you as a
tourist no longer just trudge through a
sea of forgettable dullness to get to
the one nice place rather you're
journeying across the city actually
exploring it getting to know it for
yourself compare this street in
Barcelona to walking down the streets of
Prague in Barcelona you're experiencing
your Urban surroundings in Prague you're
shimmying passed cars on a broken
sidewalk of course I'm not saying that
we should turn every street into
something out of Disneyland or that
every single Street will be a bustling
cultural Hub once the cars are gone nor
do I advocate for a full band of motor
traffic in cities after all essential
Services deliveries and trust men still
need to get to places but in cities with
proper public transit like Budapest
Prague Madrid Barcelona Paris and so on
90 of private motor traffic is
unnecessary period by unnecessary I mean
the driver chose the car out of
convenience instead of an actual
uncompromisable need this is why I
advocate for phasing out unnecessary
individual motor traffic from inside our
cities to once again bring life to a
hollowed out empty shell of what once
was a vibrant Urban fabric so that our
cities will once again be Living Spaces
by the people for the people instead of
open-air warehouses for the auto
industry's various products or to put it
in the words of the highest urban
planning experts core bad thank you for
watching and don't forget to vote for
politicians in your next local elections
who care about decongestion and
non-motorous Transit who aren't just a
bunch of concentric Boomers whose
bottoms are 60 Mercedes leather seat via
Decades of pressure osmosis see you next
time